a new sanctions pressure from Western
countries
they expected that they will quickly
destabilize the financial and economic
situation in our country provoked Panic
on the markets and caused our financial
system to collapse and to create a
deficits and show the shortages in our
shops but this policy against Russia has
collapsed this strategy of the economic
Blitzkrieg has failed moreover the
sanctions
didn't go unnoticed for the initiators
themselves there's a growth of inflation
a growth of unemployment the negative
Dynamics in the United States they drop
in the quality of life of Europeans and
the devaluation of the value in of their
savings but Russia has withstood this
unprecedented pressure the situation is
stabilizing the the exchange rates of
the ruble is
stabilizing and in the first quarter of
the year the positive
saldo has
exceeded 58 billion dollars this is a
historical maximum
cash cash
payments in foreign currencies are
returning into the Russian Financial
system and the citizens
incomes are increasing in savings
and this always happens that the
retail
demand is stabilizing we have acted
correctly when we decided not to go for
the manual regulation of the market and
have given freedom to Private Business
to look for the best effective Solutions
it is those decisions that allowed to
ensure rhythmic supplies of goods to the
retail Network and provide the necessary
products in the shops let's talk about
inflation the inflation is stabilizing
now but at the same time and we know
this very well
in over the past six weeks alone retail
prices in Russia have noticeably grown
and in the annual figures as of 8th of
April the inflation rate is 17 and a
half percent
my colleagues in the central bank and
the government we know this very well
this is a very high indicator
people feel this in their wallets they
feel the increase in prices we should
support our citizens we should help them
cope with this inflation wave in this
connection let me remind you of the
decision that we have already adopted so
index all the social payments the
pensions and the Specialists working in
the public sphere and the government
should prepare a draft decision in this
connection of course we should uh
ensure the growth in people's incomes
and creates a new jobs and to boost the
developments of the industry and other
sectors the current situation is stable
as a whole we can judge about this by
the indicator as the production of
electricity this is a good indicator it
shows that there is a positive dynamic
in the economy the number of officially
recorded unemployed is quite low of
course we should monitor the situation
and the economy on the jobs Market we
should keep our finger on the pulse and
take timely decisions to ensure the
stable and confident work of business
and entrepreneurs and the government has
done quite well in the social and the
central bank as well have done well so
far the central bank and the government
should report how you you see the
further development of the economy what
measures you should take to
avoid the deterioration of the situation
for Russian companies and citizens
before we begin to discuss today's
agenda which these are the subjects the
priorities I want to focus my attention
on today first a foreign trade the
restrictions which unfriendly countries
have imposed and Russia have impacted
the possibilities of Russian business of
course they have complicated the
logistics of foreign and domestic
supplies they were created barriers for
payments
you should support as much as possible
the business and overcoming these
problems you should help move foreign
payments in Rubles and the currencies of
friendly countries in this new
conditions we should move at a much
higher Tempo and please report to me how
this work is organized and what results
you plan
to achieve the second we should support
internal demand we should
inside the country here we should act
through the budget sphere and and also
provide additional resources to the
business this is of course the remits of
the Central Bank it has already begun to
reduce the interest rates and this will
of course make loans cheaper for the
economy as for the budgets I know that's
the central bank and the governments are
now engaged in discussions nevertheless
in the conditions of the objective drop
in
loan provision the budget should
actively support the economy and pump
Financial Resources into the economy and
supports liquidity there are resources
and possibilities
for that of course you should act
carefully but so in the first quarter of
this year there has been a record uh
level of the Prophecies of the budgets
and the we need additional Solutions uh
here and it should be done at the time
when the economy needs it the most of
course you should act carefully but the
key condition is the provision of the
long-term stability of the financial
system both at the federal and the
regional level we have about 1.1
trillion rubles now and this
accumulative prophecies in the regions
is about 1 trillion rubles